[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
hablar del caso el asesinato del
activista anti apartheid y diplomática
sudafricana su muerte en París provocó
una gran conmoción y generó
especulaciones sobre quién Y por qué se
llevó a cabo el crimen el 29 de marzo de
1988 la activista sudafricana dosis
septemberg fue asesinada a quemarropa en
pleno centro de París en la década de
1970 había sido encarcelada en su país
por sus actividades contra el régimen
segregacionista sudafricano al ser
liberada se le permitió salir de su país
con la condición de que no regresara
jamás se convirtió en la representante
del anc El Congreso Nacional africano en
Francia reconocido por ser el partido de
Nelson Mandela
era una ferviente defensora de que
Europa impusiera sanciones contra el
régimen sudafricano y respetará el
embargo de armas impuesto por las
Naciones Unidas en diciembre de 2022 la
justicia francesa falló en contra de la
familia de dosis septemberg que había
demandado al gobierno francés por
negligencia con la esperanza de reabrir
la investigación sobre su asesinato un
caso que nunca se ha resuelto Pero qué
sabían los servicios secretos franceses
acaso el activista sudafricana fue
asesinada por investigar el tráfico de
armas entre Sudáfrica y Francia Esta es
la historia
arcoy la roja como era conocido era
lugar favorito del exilio de september
en esta comunidad Obrera se sentía
segura vivía en el cuarto piso de este
edificio
Yaquelín en ese entonces profesora de
inglés y activista contra la parcaid le
ayudó a traducir sus comunicados
aquí vivió de enero de 1987 a marzo de
1988 dollsy septemberg
representante del CNA en Francia
asesinada el 29 de marzo de 1988 por el
régimen del apartado
homenaje de la ciudad de arcoíris
era adicta al trabajo no se le escapaba
nada Recuerda una llamada que me hizo a
la 1 de la madrugada me dijo te das
cuenta de que hay un cantante que se va
a Sudáfrica hay sanciones no es posible
Qué haces Estás durmiendo hablaba muy
poco francés Pero había aprendido la
palabra copié dormir
le dije Bueno sí ya veremos mañana
una persona completamente entregada a la
causa la había podado la incorruptible
más la visión colectiva el primer exilio
de Dulce recién salida de las cárceles
de la parte fue Londres Luego llegó a
Francia en 1983 orgullosa de representar
al movimiento de Liberación en los
últimos meses de su vida le dijo al
alcalde comunista de arcoil que se
sentía seguida no lo suficiente para que
el gobierno francés le concediera
protección
fue Cuando entró en su despacho del 28
que fue asesinada dos hombres le
esperaban le dispararon al salir del
ascensor recibió cinco impactos de bala
a quemarropa y luego le dispararon en la
nuca para rematarla los falsos pintores
llevaban varias semanas espiando la
oficina nunca los volvieron a ver
Esta activista es ahora un ícono en los
suburbios mestizos de Ciudad del Cabo
donde nació ella se había refugiado en
el país de los Derechos Humanos donde
pensaba que podía decir cualquier cosa
es la única representante del CNA que ha
sido ejecutada fuera del continente
africano
[Música]
35 años después del asesinato sus amigos
no han pasado página el abogado its
Logan amigo íntimo del abogado de Nelson
Mandela se hizo cargo del caso y nunca
dejó de buscar la verdad rechaza la
tesis de que la justicia francesa
califique este asunto de derecho común y
denuncia una investigación mediocre el
caso tardó 13 días en remitirse a un
fiscal la fiscalía pidió la suspensión
del procedimiento estoy bastante seguro
y así concluyó el juez concluyó y ordenó
archivar El caso es decir nunca hubo
audiencia pública todo esto ocurría en
oficinas y pasillos nunca hubo una
audiencia nunca hubo un debate
significa que es un asunto de estado hay
una razón de estado porque se trata de
las relaciones entre Francia y Sudáfrica
durante todo el periodo de lapard
durante 40 años y este expediente no
debe abrirse a fuerza de perseverancia
el abogado Logan consiguió hacerse oír
el pasado mes de noviembre en el Palacio
de justicia de París la familia y los
amigos de Dulce estuvieron allí para
apoyarle
Estoy aprovechando este es nuestro
comunicado de prensa no sé si te lo
envié
la vista esa Puerta cerrada y el abogado
solo dispondrá de 20 minutos para alegar
para la justicia francesa
independientemente de las resoluciones
votadas por Francia en el Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU El crimen de la
parkate solo se reconoce a partir de la
ley francesa de 2013
se alinee es trágico se trata de alinear
la posición jurídica de Francia con la
del régimen de lapard en los años 80
ambos países han repudiado El crimen del
apartheid es una locura para la imagen
de Francia es desgarrador es hora de que
el poder judicial se ponga las pilas
[Música]
la familia de dulcee
para nosotros no hay fecha de caducidad
queremos que se haga justicia
[Música]
el estado francés no fue transparente
cuando los miembros de la comisión de la
verdad y la reconciliación encargada de
investigar los crímenes vinieron a pedir
más información
sin embargo eugenek jefe de un escuadrón
de la muerte declaró en abril de 1998
que la muerte de dulzi estaba
probablemente relacionada con los
intercambios entre pretoria y París
incluso mencionó el nombre de un antiguo
paracaidista francés nunca se escuchó
hoy en día nadie sabe dónde está
en los archivos de la anc quedan muy
pocas notas personales de su
representante en París
pero lo poco que queda sugiere que
estaba investigando el abuso del embargo
de armas estas notas por ejemplo sobre
un barco que salió de burdeos con dos
mil toneladas de material destinado
falsamente Argentina que llegó a urbano
la desclasificación de documentos
militares sudafricanos permitirá más
tarde comprender los compromisos de los
gobiernos europeos con el régimen de la
parte
en 2017 un grupo de investigadores de la
Unión Europea publicó una notable
investigación demuestran que una
treintena de países han permitido el
desvío del embargo con la complicidad de
200 bancos
en aquella época Francia era junto con
Israel el centro de neurálgico de la
venta de armas en este contexto fue
asesinada dulce y september
gracias a una de nuestras Fuentes
pudimos establecer que un sudafricano
sacó de contrabando el arma homicida de
Europa
y sabemos el retrospectiva que la
policía francesa hizo desaparecer todos
sus documentos importantes tras su
asesinato
Pero quizá lo más importante sea
comprender las redes que se beneficiaron
de este delito
la empresa sudafricana de armamento Arms
tuvo sus oficinas durante 20 años en la
embajada de Sudáfrica en París
unos 30 funcionarios algunos con
pasaporte diplomático se encargaban de
comprar y vender armas en toda Europa
hay muy pocas dudas las autoridades
francesas lo sabían
contactado por teléfono
antiguo miembro de los servicios de
inteligencia franceses cuyo nombre se
menciona varias veces en los archivos
sudafricanos declinó hacer comentarios
también Afirma no tener información
sobre el asesinato de dulce y septemberg
cuando trabajaba en 1988 en el
ayuntamiento de París
latente cordial entre París y pretoria
trasciende las divisiones políticas
la central nuclear de keber negociaba
desde 1974 bajo el mandato de Jack
shirak como Primer Ministro se terminó
en 1985 al año siguiente París vendió 66
helicópteros superpuma y los
sudafricanos adaptaron y rebautizaron
ónix un contrato firmado bajo la
presidencia de françois en 1987 el misil
Mistral que el ejército francés aún no
había desplegado fue ofrecido a los
sudafricanos para que lo probaran en
Angola este antiguo soldado sudafricano
que encontramos cerca de urbana confirma
que Las Guerras en el sur de África
sirvieron de campo de pruebas para el
equipo militar francés
[Música]
estábamos volando helicóptero superlibre
en 1987 este hombre fue reclutado por
los servicios sudafricanos para llevar a
cabo operaciones en Europa viajaba con
un nombre falso Roger y nos muestra
complacido sus archivos
Este es el nivel de detalle en el que
estamos trabajando
puede ver aquí en los planos
Miren esta es Leal
supervisó misiones en toda Europa hasta
1990 pero dice que le sorprendió el
asesinato de Dulce september que ahora
califica de desafortunado y que le
sorprendió mucho su muerte
nunca he tenido información de que los
servicios secretos estuvieran Implicados
En esta operación por supuesto se dice
que Sudáfrica intentaba aterrorizar a
los militantes
desestabilizar al CNA
Ahora puedo decirte que desde mi punto
de vista desde mi perspectiva como
operador esta operación fue
contraproducente queríamos que nuestros
enemigos se sintieran cómodos
nos encantaba la vigilancia electrónica
colocábamos micrófonos en todas las
oficinas lo que nos permitió recopilar
mucha información
y ahora tenemos a alguien que está
provocando el caos entre los activistas
del CNA en el exilio
se obsesionan con la seguridad y ya no
hablan como antes
así que esto es contraproducente para
nosotros
pero lo que puedo decir hoy es que
también teníamos vaqueros los vaqueros
ocupaban el campo y eran extremadamente
nacionalistas eran de extrema derecha
casi neonazis
el régimen de la parte tenía su quinta
columna compuesto por mercenarios en su
mayoría agentes dobles que trabajaban
tanto para París como para pretoria uno
de ellos Richard guyé antiguo activista
de derechas fue el primer acusado en el
caso de septiembre lo conocimos en
Sudáfrica Afirma haber sido víctima de
una guerra de servicios cuando trabajaba
con Bob en las comoras le pagaban los
sudafricanos que utilizaban la isla de
las comunas para el tránsito de armas
que luego navegaban tranquilamente hacia
Sudáfrica
esos acuerdos son ahora conocidos por
los activistas
este sudafricano trabajó durante años en
la clandestinidad conoció a Dulce y
september él sabe que ella fue expuesta
tuvo que haber informado sobre lo que
sabía a Londres
ella debe haber enviado mensajes a los
rangos más altos allí
lo que hoy sabemos es que había agentes
dobles eslabones débiles personas que
informaban al enemigo a veces incluso
sin saberlo
y que nos muestra en su diario el nombre
de soly Smith El ayudante de dulce y
september que ahora se sabe era un
informante de la policía de la Park hate
la organización estaba infiltrada y
mucha gente lo sabe
porque nunca dijeron nada
intentaban proteger a altos cargos de la
anc O del partido comunista sudafricano
sí
la anc se resiste a hablar de estas
horas oscuras los expresidentes tabón
Becky exiliados desde hace tiempo en
Londres y Jacob suma figura clave en la
lucha clandestina nunca se han
pronunciado
solo una persona accedió a recibirnos un
antiguo combatiente de la lucha armada
responsable de inteligencia en
mozambique
el CNA era plenamente consciente de todo
lo que estaba ocurriendo sabemos mucho
más de lo que imaginas en Francia
realmente había un clima de derecha dura
y este tipo de clima facilita el
reclutamiento de partidarios de la parte
y estaban a salvo en ese país podían
operar fácilmente
habría sido mucho más complicado si
hubiera riesgo pero no lo había ni
entonces Ni ahora
el 29 de marzo de cada año se rinde
homenaje en pretoria a Dulce y september
su nombre está grabado en el muro de Los
Héroes entre otros 75.000 ladrillos las
víctimas de la parte
y cada año una personalidad lanza un
nuevo llamamiento
[Música]
y somos nosotros los ciudadanos
sudafricanos quienes debemos presionar a
nuestro gobierno para que se dirija al
gobierno francés y le diga queremos que
estos documentos que pertenecieron al
Dolce y septemberg que fueron
confiscados por la policía francesa este
año se inició una investigación policial
en Sudáfrica la familia Espera que los
dos países cooperen algún día
sin ningún tribunal francés acepta
nuestro caso
estamos considerando la posibilidad de
recurrir al tribunal europeo de los
derechos humanos
con el paso del tiempo los recuerdos se
desvanecen y los Testigos mueren
irónicamente la mujer que luchó toda su
vida para sacar a la luz la verdad de un
régimen opresor corre el riesgo de que
se le niegue para siempre la justicia en
el país de los Derechos Humanos
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta 35 años después del
asesinato de dosis una mujer que dejó un
legado duradero y un recordatorio de los
peligros que enfrentaban los activistas
anti apartheit recuerde que puede
Ingresar a nuestra página web France
24.com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores hasta la próxima
[Música]